i'm happy already time for the uplifted
hey where we share the stories that will
bring you some joy to your day i got new
smile lines because of this segment good
morning hey good morning it is time for
the uplift and let me ask you a question
uh-huh have you ever worked so hard for
something and wanted it so badly you
could hardly stand it yep you know what
that's like yep you know what that's
like folks check out this woman's
reaction when she got the results of her
bar exam to become a lawyer watch this
[Music]
oh my god what do you think happened she
passed
she better
she passed that is christina gulligen
with her family she posted this video on
tick tock and it has gotten more than
one million views awesome she told us
getting the results was much more
nerve-wracking than even studying
you can't say okay i could put in a
couple more hours or i could do this or
i could review this like you have no
control over it anymore so
leading up to it i was a wreck and i was
just so so nervous
christina was officially sworn in
earlier this month by a judge who was
also her former professor uh it takes so
much work oh yeah just to get to the
point where you're taking the bar
exactly i know and your stomach is all
like got butterflies and then you find
out you passed yeah
it's no fun i haven't taken it i know
plenty of people who have